programming throwdown episode 2020 holiday edition take it away j Jason. Hey, everybody. Happy holidays. It's been a wild year. We'll definitely recap a lot of the year. We'll answer questions that came in from y'all. And yeah, it's been crazy. How are you feeling, Patrick? I feel best described as all those memes of people making things that say, 2020, I survived.
Programming Throwdown 2020假日特辑，Jason，开始吧。嘿，大家好。节日快乐。这真是疯狂的一年。我们肯定会回顾这一年的很多事情。我们会回答你们发来的问题。是的，这一年太疯狂了。Patrick，你感觉如何？我觉得最好的描述就是那些人们制作的写着“2020，我活下来了”的表情包。
I survived 2020. But then people pointing out correctly that they're still at the time of this recording. Yeah, still like, you know, 10, 15 days left. So that might be a bit premature. Yeah, you never know. Yeah, the you had the the the virus thing just really exploded in california so so neither of us are actually in california right now um but uh but but you know talking to people who are there it's uh it's pretty intense what's going on there yeah i mean my best wishes go out to everyone affected by this i think it's easy uh you personally, I've been fairly lucky to have avoided any major health consequences in my immediate family or
我熬过了2020年。但人们正确地指出，在录制这段音频时，这一年还没过完。是的，你知道，还有10到15天。所以这可能有点操之过急了。是的，你永远不知道会发生什么。是的，病毒在加州真的爆发了，所以我们俩现在其实都不在加州。但是，和那里的人交谈时，你会发现那里发生的事情相当紧张。是的，我的意思是，我向所有受此影响的人致以最美好的祝愿。我认为这很容易……就你个人而言，我相当幸运，我的直系亲属没有受到任何重大的健康影响，或者
extended family. But that's not true for a lot of people. And I think it's easy sometimes, for some people who haven't been affected to, to kind of shortchange how serious this has all been for people who have been affected by losing jobs, losing family members. I mean, for those people, it's, uh, it's been even worse of a ride. Yeah. Yeah. That's a really good point. It's been totally wild. Yeah. I think one of the things that, that is pretty shocking is, um, is, is the, the, they're calling it like the K shaped curve, but basically it's just completely bifurcated like some people um you know are actually you know kind of benefiting i mean not on purpose but some people are just benefiting from from the virus and just the changes that it had on
大家庭也没有。但对很多人来说并非如此。我认为，对于一些没有受到影响的人来说，有时很容易低估这对那些因失业、失去亲人而受到影响的人来说有多么严重。我的意思是，对这些人来说，这甚至是一段更糟糕的旅程。是的。是的。这是一个非常好的观点。这真是太疯狂了。是的。我认为令人震惊的事情之一是，他们称之为“K型曲线”，但基本上它完全分叉了。有些人，你知道，实际上在某种程度上受益了，我的意思是并非故意，但有些人确实从病毒以及它对整个社会环境的影响中受益。
the whole like social environment and uh and other people are really devastated. And it's kind of a really weird position to situation to see. So, I mean, yeah, trying to pivot it into technology. I mean, this has been a, you know, having paid dues to the seriousness of it. I mean, for a lot of tech companies, e-commerce, digital stuff, I mean, it's coming into its own. Like people are figuring out video conferencing, and a lot of the problems we discussed in a couple episodes, you know, I think online stores are getting credit as being, you know, equivalent to shopping in in person that,
而另一些人则受到了沉重的打击。看到这种情况真的很奇怪。所以，我的意思是，试着转向技术领域。我的意思是，在承认其严重性的前提下，对于许多科技公司、电子商务、数字产品来说，它正在走向成熟。人们正在弄清楚视频会议，我们在几期节目中讨论过的许多问题，我认为在线商店正被视为等同于亲自购物，
you know, we're in the holiday season now. And I haven't gone and shopped in in a store for holiday gifts. I, you know, I've been trending that way. But now, this year, it's a, you know, serious thing. It's like, why would I not just order everything from a website? That sounds great. Yeah, it's so true. And, and, uh, yeah, we, I mentioned this on a past episode, but you know, the big thing for me was clothes. Um, yeah, I've always felt like, oh, I should get, you know, clothes in person and get the right, you know, fit and things like that. And, uh, and now it's just, it's just like, yeah, just because of the right you know fit and things like that and uh and now it's just it's just like yeah just because of necessity you know we started getting them online and then we kind of
你知道，我们现在处于假日季节。我还没有去商店买过节日礼物。我，你知道，一直有这种趋势。但今年，这是一个严重的问题。就像，为什么我不直接从网站上订购所有东西呢？听起来不错。是的，确实如此。而且，我过去在节目中提到过这一点，但你知道，对我来说最大的变化是衣服。嗯，我一直觉得，哦，我应该亲自去买衣服，找到合适的尺码等等。而现在，这就像，仅仅是因为必要性，我们开始在网上购买，然后我们意识到，
realized that like oh actually i'm not really as picky as i thought i was and so yeah i'm really probably just going to buy clothes online you know uh forever now and so that's a huge change yeah i mean this this year um you know, from a from a job stint has been, you know, thankful that I haven't, you know, had any major changes to my role or position or anything. But you know, being remote since March has been has been completely crazy. That before, you know, at most, maybe you'd be like a day or two, if you were, you know, had something or under the weather or whatever. But now, you know, it's just like a full time thing being being in the house and doing online meetings and doing coding. And I think not everyone has,
哦，其实我并没有我想象中那么挑剔，所以是的，我可能以后永远都会在网上买衣服了，这是一个巨大的改变。是的，我的意思是，今年，从工作角度来看，我很庆幸我的角色或职位没有任何重大变化。但是，自三月份以来一直远程办公，这简直太疯狂了。以前，你知道，最多也就是一两天，如果你有什么事或者身体不舒服之类的。但现在，你知道，这就像全职在家，进行在线会议和编写代码。我认为并不是每个人都，
you know, reacted in some way for me personally, I've actually, you know, kind of, I guess I, it's been my jam, like, I don't go up the house for a while you know i have to be conscious to make sure to continue exercise and stuff um but being able to to do my work remotely has actually been a pretty cool opportunity for something that otherwise wouldn't have been afforded yeah i feel exactly the same way i think that that um i was really worried about the communication part of it, as you would expect. I was worried that we basically wouldn't have those times
你知道，以某种方式做出反应。对我个人而言，我其实，我想，这很适合我，比如，我有一段时间不出门，你知道，我必须有意识地确保继续锻炼之类的。但能够远程工作实际上是一个相当不错的机会，否则我可能不会有这样的机会。是的，我的感觉完全一样。我认为，我真的很担心沟通方面的问题，正如你所预料的那样。我担心我们基本上不会有那些时间
to sync together as a team. We'd lose some of that synergy. But it actually worked out really, really well. We block certain times for a social time. And so a lot of it is done over VC. We block certain times for social time. And so a lot of it is done over VC. I think the biggest challenge is people interrupting each other because of that delay. But we're starting to find good ways to solve that as well.
作为团队同步。我们会失去一些协同效应。但实际上效果非常好。我们为社交时间预留了特定的时间。所以很多事情都是通过视频会议完成的。我们为社交时间预留了特定的时间。所以很多事情都是通过视频会议完成的。我认为最大的挑战是人们因为延迟而互相打断。但我们也开始找到解决这个问题的好方法了。
And yeah, I think the freedom of it has been awesome. And being able to do your laundry while you work and a lot of the things you would imagine are really useful they actually are i mean it saves so much time in your day i think also um communication has been i don't like maybe that word is overused but more conscientious like i think people or at least i do personally try to take more care because you can't do the in-, you know, facial expression stuff as well over video, I feel so like when I do reviews or emails, or even just, you know,
是的，我认为这种自由度太棒了。能够在你工作时洗衣服，以及你想象中很多真正有用的事情，它们确实很有用。我的意思是，这节省了你一天中很多时间。我认为沟通也变得，我不知道，也许这个词被过度使用了，但更认真了。因为我认为人们，或者至少我个人，尝试更加小心，因为你不能在视频中很好地表达面部表情。所以我感觉，当我做评论或写邮件，甚至只是，你知道，
instant messaging people that I, you know, take care to make sure to say more of what I'm thinking or how I'm dealing or how I'm planning something or approaching things. And in some ways, I think that's helped me organize my thought patterns a little bit better by having to be more specific rather than just, hey, so and so come over here, or let's go grab a room or let's go get, you know, a snack or something, right? Like trying to be more thoughtful about, hey, I'm going to engage this person with that topic. And, you know, bring in this other, you know what I mean? Like, I think those things have been actually slightly better because you're more deliberate about including people than just whoever happens to be around
给人们发即时消息时，我会注意确保说出更多我的想法，或者我如何处理，或者我如何计划某事或处理事情。在某些方面，我认为这通过不得不更具体，而不是仅仅说“某某过来这里”，或者“我们去开个会”或者“我们去吃点零食”之类的，帮助我更好地组织了我的思维模式。就像尝试更周到地思考，“嘿，我要和这个人讨论这个话题”。而且，你知道，引入其他人，你明白我的意思吗？就像，我认为这些事情实际上稍微好一点，因为你更有意识地去包容别人，而不是仅仅因为谁碰巧在身边
when you have a thought. Yeah, totally agree. And, and the other thing is, you know, anything now is kind of, you're always kind of asking someone's permission because it's a VC. So it's just, it's a lot more deliberate. And so, um, it kind of gives people the opportunity to kind of schedule when they want to have those chats. Whereas when it's in person,
当你有一个想法时。是的，完全同意。还有一件事是，你知道，现在任何事情，你总是要征求某人的许可，因为这是视频会议。所以它更加深思熟虑。因此，它给了人们机会去安排他们想要进行这些聊天的时间。而在面对面时，
if someone walks up to you and says, hey, do you have a minute? You're just really compelled to say yes, even if you really don't have a minute. But if someone messages you, there's sort of this plausible deniability, like maybe the person wasn't at their phone or whatever. And so, as you said,
如果有人走过来问你，嘿，你有空吗？你真的会被迫说“有”，即使你真的没空。但如果有人给你发消息，就会有一种合理的推诿，比如也许那个人不在手机旁之类的。所以，正如你所说，
it allows people time to concentrate before a discussion. Yeah, I feel that initially there was this like, oh, no, how am I going to get my questions answered? But I think it turns out actually like waiting around for an answer. Sometimes you fix it yourself or sometimes you do something else. And I think it turns out you just don't need as fast of answers as we were maybe used to getting in the office. Yep. Yeah, exactly. Cool. Yeah, I think or do you think you're going to stay remote for the foreseeable future? We'll see. I mean, I think it's gonna vary as companies figure out their plans and work. I think for sure. I think a lot of, you know, we're both in, in programming, but, and in companies which are technology focused. So I think maybe our view is
它让人们在讨论之前有时间集中注意力。是的，我感觉最初有这种“哦，不，我该怎么得到我的问题的答案？”的想法。但我认为结果实际上是，等待答案。有时你自己解决了，或者有时你做了别的事情。我认为结果是你并不需要像我们在办公室里习惯的那样快速得到答案。是的。是的，完全正确。酷。是的，我想，或者你认为你会在可预见的未来保持远程办公吗？我们会看到的。我的意思是，我认为随着公司制定他们的计划和工作，情况会有所不同。我认为肯定会。我认为很多，你知道，我们都在编程领域，但在以技术为中心的公司中。所以我认为也许我们的观点
a little skewed. I think a lot of programmers work in industries which aren't completely only a tech company, right? So there's a lot of programming jobs for, uh, you know, whatever you want to think like refrigerator manufacturers or car manufacturers or, you know, whatever you want to think like refrigerator manufacturers or car manufacturers or, you know, things which are more mixed, or even people making furniture, I guess, right, need various kinds of programming. So I think a lot of, you know, jobs are going to have adopted technology to deal with this that they wouldn't have otherwise. And I'm curious to see the impact that's going to have on the like, who stays remote and who stays remote and who, you know, goes back to the office or needs to be in the office because real estate is pretty expensive in a lot of places in the Bay Area of San Francisco and California, that I think what you're seeing is that a lot of them are going to be away from the office for at least, you know,
有点偏颇。我认为很多程序员在并非完全是科技公司的行业工作，对吧？所以有很多编程工作是为，你知道，任何你想到的，比如冰箱制造商或汽车制造商，或者，你知道，任何你想到的，比如冰箱制造商或汽车制造商，或者，你知道，更混合的事情，甚至制造家具的人，我想，对吧，也需要各种编程。所以我认为很多工作将会采用技术来处理这个问题，否则他们就不会这样做了。我很好奇这会产生什么影响，比如谁保持远程，谁保持远程，谁，你知道，回到办公室或需要回到办公室，因为房地产在旧金山湾区和加州的很多地方都很贵，我认为你看到的是，他们中的许多人将至少在离开办公室，你知道，
14, 16, 18 months before they're going to sort of staff back up. And that's a long time to have people be remote and learn how to deal with that and then just suddenly bring them all back to the office yeah actually um um i was thinking about this the liability dimension here is like really really interesting um you know if you uh if you ask people to come back well there's there's so many different angles this i mean one is you know can employers force people to be vaccinated to come to work so that's a whole thing that's we're going to be careful here keep going yeah yeah yeah no i'm not going to get into the ethical issues there but but but but the but then there's like okay assuming that doesn't happen or assuming they've taken employer for which you know they don't have that mandate well then if anybody um uh you know if they set a line and say okay it's you know i don't know april and everyone has to come back and even one person um you know gets gets gets extremely sick
14、16、18个月，然后才会重新开始配备人员。让人们远程工作并学习如何处理这个问题，然后突然把他们全部带回办公室，这需要很长时间。是的，实际上，我一直在思考这个问题，这里的责任维度真的非常有趣。你知道，如果你要求人们回来，嗯，这里有太多不同的角度了。我的意思是，一个是，你知道，雇主可以强迫人们接种疫苗才能来工作吗？所以这是一个完整的问题，我们在这里要小心，继续。是的，是的，不，我不会深入探讨那里的道德问题，但是，但是，但是，但是，然后有，好吧，假设这没有发生，或者假设他们已经采取了雇主，你知道，他们没有那个授权，那么如果任何人，你知道，如果他们设定了一条线，说好吧，是四月，每个人都必须回来，甚至一个人，你知道，变得非常非常生病
um because they were kind of you know mandated to come back. That's a real, real problem. You know, and even if like legally, you know, there's, they're in the right, I think it, it, in the court of popular opinion, I mean, it's going to become a real issue. And so to your point, I think what's going to happen is, I think that, that for people who are asked to go remote, you know, I think Mike, I think it was Twitter who are asked to go remote, I think it was Twitter who initially did this. They said anyone who is asked to go remote can come back basically at will, indefinitely. And I think that's going to become the policy.
因为他们被要求回来。这是一个真正的问题。你知道，即使在法律上，你知道，他们是正确的，我认为在公众舆论中，我的意思是，这将成为一个真正的问题。所以回到你的观点，我认为会发生的是，我认为对于那些被要求远程工作的人，你知道，我想Mike，我想是Twitter最初这样做的。他们说任何被要求远程工作的人都可以基本上随意回来，无限期。我认为这会成为政策。
I wouldn't be surprised if all of these companies say, look, if you are interviewing now, we're going to ask you to come in. We get to set the rules, but for the people who we asked to go remote, um, you know, we're not going to mandate for them to come back because otherwise I think it, it, it opens up this whole can of worms. I think this is something we'll definitely be revisiting on this podcast. Yeah. So actually, yeah, well, that's my prediction. So, you know, we always do our predictions i'll just say mine right away my prediction for 2021 is that and you know obviously it's not everyone
如果所有这些公司都说，看，如果你现在正在面试，我们会要求你进来。我们有权制定规则，但对于我们要求远程工作的人，我们不会强制他们回来，因为否则我认为这会打开潘多拉的盒子。我认为这是我们肯定会在这个播客中重新讨论的话题。是的。所以实际上，是的，好吧，这是我的预测。所以，你知道，我们总是做我们的预测，我会马上说出我的。我对2021年的预测是，你知道，显然不是每个人
but but the big companies um you know the fang um and and and the other sort of like the big players oracle and those cisco um that they're not going to have like a hard mandate to come back there will be strong encouragement but that there won't be any mandate that's my prediction are we doing predictions now i'll do mine yeah go for it what's your prediction my prediction is harkening back to a one i made a long time ago but i'll make it again i think this year you're going to hear a ton of news about um basically the new space race i think there's going to be this is not really a program i think sorry but i think that's great i think blue origin is very close you've got um the boeing activities with what is that i guess orion spacex the man i was so stoked i watched
但是大公司，你知道，FANG，以及其他像甲骨文、思科这样的大玩家，他们不会有强制回来的硬性规定。会有强烈的鼓励，但不会有任何强制要求。这是我的预测。我们现在在做预测吗？我会做我的。是的，来吧。你的预测是什么？我的预测是回顾我很久以前做的一个预测，但我会再做一次。我认为今年你会听到大量关于，基本上是新太空竞赛的新闻。我认为会有，这不是一个程序，对不起，但我认为这很棒。我认为蓝色起源非常接近了。你有波音的活动，那是，我想是猎户座，SpaceX。伙计，我太兴奋了，我看了
the starship launch from spacex it was like so close and i was crazy watched it with my kids and i was just thinking like i think one day and I took a video of them watching the video. I don't know. Maybe that's weird. But yeah, I just like I think one day it'll be like look back and be like, this is the start of when, you know, things started to change. And even just looking, you know, I'm not like making picks about which company will win or lose because I think there's only been a few years. So I think in the scale of these kinds of things, a decade even isn't
SpaceX的星舰发射。它太接近了，我太疯狂了。我和我的孩子们一起看了，我当时就在想，我想有一天，我拍了一段他们看视频的视频。我不知道。也许这很奇怪。但是的，我只是觉得有一天回首往事会说，这是事情开始改变的开始。甚至只是看着，你知道，我不是在挑选哪家公司会赢或输，因为我认为才过去几年。所以我认为在这些事情的规模上，十年甚至都不是
that long of a time. And so I think, you know, we're going to see this as like one of the areas where it's an inflection point. And the amount of people and things and objects and technology going to space in a given year is going to start to be is going to become exponential, you start to see the statistics, like, if some of these quotas keep ramping up you're going to have more weight launched into space in a year than all of previous mankind well it's a short thing i guess but you know spacex is on track i think there's something like they are i think i want to say like in the first half of the year almost booked out like one launch one paid launch a like in the first half of the year, almost booked out like one launch, one paid launch a week in the first half of 2021 or something. So I was going to ask you,
那么长的时间。所以我认为，你知道，我们将把这视为一个拐点。每年进入太空的人、事物、物体和技术的数量将开始呈指数级增长。你开始看到统计数据，比如，如果其中一些配额继续增加，你每年发射到太空的重量将超过以往全人类的总和。好吧，这可能是一个简短的事情，但我知道SpaceX正在步入正轨。我想有一些事情，比如他们，我想说，在上半年几乎预订满了，一次发射，一次付费发射，在上半年，几乎预订满了，一次发射，一次付费发射，在2021年上半年每周一次之类的。所以我正要问你，
what's the economic value. It's, it's tourists who want to do space, like ground trips, space travel. I think all of it. Right. So you see the stuff like the Starling satellite internet has, it could be game changing,
经济价值是什么。是想要进行太空旅行的游客，比如地面旅行，太空旅行。我认为都是。对吧。所以你看到像星链卫星互联网这样的东西，它可能是改变游戏规则的，
right? If you can live wherever, and especially with this coupled with the coronavirus stuff the covid stuff right if you could suddenly be in a cabin and have high speed low latency internet via satellite for a reasonable price think of like what that changes to the dynamics of like where people want to live and work um how is that connected to the to the space right like Can't they already do that? I know nothing about that. So I think it's, you know, if you launch a satellite and it's, you know, it's like per pound.
对吧？如果你可以住在任何地方，特别是结合这种冠状病毒的事情，新冠的事情，对吧？如果你突然可以在一个小屋里，通过卫星以合理的价格获得高速、低延迟的互联网，想想这会如何改变人们想要居住和工作的地方的动态。这与太空有什么联系？他们不能已经那样做了吗？我对那一点都不了解。所以我认为，你知道，如果你发射一颗卫星，它是，你知道，它是按重量计算的。
So if you can drop the price per pound by an order of magnitude, you can afford to put up a lot more satellites. And you need a dense coverage of satellites and then also because you spent less making them and getting them into space if they only last you know five six seven years which is true for objects in very low earth orbit then you can that's that's an economically feasible thing to do if you had to pay 10 times the amount you need your satellite to either deliver more economic value or be up for longer and so that just eliminates parts of the design space so spacex to send up someone else's satellite in half the capacity and then 50 of their starlink satellites and the other half of the capacity of the you know way they can basically
所以如果你能将每磅的价格降低一个数量级，你就可以负担得起发射更多的卫星。你需要密集的卫星覆盖，而且因为你花在制造它们并将它们送入太空的钱更少，如果它们只持续，你知道，五、六、七年，这对极低地球轨道上的物体来说是真的，那么你就可以，这在经济上是可行的。如果你必须支付10倍的金额，你需要你的卫星要么提供更多的经济价值，要么运行更长时间，而这只是消除了设计空间的一部分。所以SpaceX发送别人的卫星，占用一半的容量，然后是他们自己的50颗星链卫星，占用另一半的容量，你知道，他们基本上可以
for a very cheap amount get all those satellites up um and then they don't need them to stay up that long before they are a net positive return on their capital oh i see but it's not just six and starlink i mean there are other companies waiting in the wings to do the same thing so as soon as there's cheap reliable frequent you know flights to space it becomes kind of like commercial business travel right that like suddenly there were people at my job, and especially from my previous job, who would just fly two, three times a week to various places rather than getting on a phone and calling someone. And that was because it was considerably cheap to be able to do that. And if space becomes the same thing, I don't think it'll become like
以非常便宜的价格把所有那些卫星送上去，然后他们不需要它们停留那么久，就能获得资本的净正回报。哦，我明白了。但这不仅仅是SpaceX和星链，我的意思是还有其他公司在等待做同样的事情。所以一旦有廉价、可靠、频繁的太空飞行，它就变得有点像商业商务旅行，对吧？突然间，我的工作中，特别是从我以前的工作中，有人会每周飞两三次到各个地方，而不是打电话给某人。这是因为能够这样做相当便宜。如果太空也变成这样，我不认为它会变成像
cost of a flight, but an airplane flight, but if it becomes cheap like that, all of a flight but um an airplane flight but if it becomes cheap like that all of a sudden what is reasonable to put in space including humans for entertainment value becomes way more open and possible that makes sense so like the the russian space station right things the iss right um so that is in orbit around the earth is that does that need a lot of maintenance i mean i have to i'm totally you know a dummy on this yeah we completely have that you have is that could you have like clubs in space where people go spend like two days like or like maybe not a club like a resort resort in space i mean i think so right so the early ones like Virgin Galactic, and I think to some extent, the Blue Origin current rocket would be, you know, giving people four or five, six minutes of weightlessness, you won't actually reach orbit. So they're a little bit of a different thing. And that's what we'll see sort of first from them. But then once you get more powerful things like the starship from SpaceX, then yeah, I mean, I think you could start to have um places in space for people to go to and and sort of hang out for a day or a week you know like a very expensive resort I guess although for a while it's still going to be very uncomfortable because getting large objects up is
飞机航班的成本，但如果它变得像那样便宜，突然之间，包括人类在内的太空娱乐价值变得更加开放和可能。这说得通。所以，比如俄罗斯空间站，国际空间站，对吧？它在绕地球轨道运行，那需要很多维护吗？我的意思是，我完全是一个门外汉。是的，我们完全有那个。你是否有，你可以在太空中有俱乐部，人们去那里待上两天，或者也许不是俱乐部，而是度假村，太空度假村？我的意思是，我想是的，对吧？所以早期的，比如维珍银河，我认为在某种程度上，蓝色起源目前的火箭会是，你知道，给人们四、五、六分钟的失重，你实际上不会到达轨道。所以它们有点不同。这就是我们首先会从他们那里看到的。但一旦你有了更强大的东西，比如SpaceX的星舰，那么是的，我的意思是，我认为你可以开始在太空中有地方让人们去，并待上一天或一周，你知道，像一个非常昂贵的度假村，我想。虽然有一段时间它仍然会非常不舒服，因为把大型物体送上去
still going to be pretty hard um you can get heavy objects up but getting really big objects up is oh yeah that makes sense it's still going to be hard. And so I think you will start to see some of that. That might be a little further out. But I think first just being able to get satellites up for cheaper, I think is going to be very interesting. And then longer term, you start to, like you say, start to do more colonization of orbit or the moon or even Mars, but also about like asteroid mining and stuff
仍然会相当困难。你可以把重物送上去，但把非常大的物体送上去，哦，是的，这说得通，仍然会很困难。所以我认为你会开始看到其中的一些。那可能还要再远一点。但我认为首先只是能够以更便宜的价格把卫星送上去，我认为会非常有趣。然后从长远来看，你开始，就像你说的，开始做更多的轨道、月球甚至火星的殖民，但也关于小行星采矿之类的
right like a single selectively picked asteroid has like more precious metals than is like on the entire earth and so you can completely change things which are too expensive now like gold if you find one of these asteroids people are supposing you might be able to like have more gold like 10 times more gold than exists on the whole planet right now. So that changes what you could use gold for because suddenly it's not an expensive thing. Wow. I wonder if you,
对吧，一颗被精选的小行星拥有的贵金属比整个地球上的还要多，所以你可以彻底改变现在太昂贵的事情，比如黄金。如果你找到这些小行星之一，人们假设你可能能够拥有更多的黄金，比如比现在整个星球上存在的黄金多10倍。所以这改变了你可以使用黄金的地方，因为突然之间它不再是一件昂贵的东西。哇。我想知道如果你，
if you were going to mine an asteroid and it's, it's not that far away, I wonder if you would send chunks of it into the earth, you know, versus just having to carry it all back. I think there's lots of ideas here i think a lot of it will depend on what and how safely and easily and how big of things you can send into orbit or not wow that's wild okay so that's a pretty bold prediction so
如果你要开采一颗小行星，而且它离得不远，我想知道你会把它的碎片送到地球，你知道，而不是必须把它们全部带回来。我认为这里有很多想法。我认为很多将取决于你可以发送什么，以及你可以多安全、多容易、多大的东西进入轨道。哇，这太疯狂了。好吧，这是一个相当大胆的预测，所以
you're saying so the prediction is basically that there are space race there's basically going to be a lot more competition in the space arena and a lot more like to make a specific one i'd say you're going to see uh the first regularly scheduled uh tourist launches by the end of 2021 so i think yeah that sounds awesome i don't know i should look at their schedules first they probably published their schedules so i could probably cheat yeah you look it's like oh well there goes that bet um yeah my my uh prediction last year for this year was that um i believe it was that i'll have to double check but i think it was that education or maybe that was we had a long-term and a short-term bet um i think the long-term bet for me was that
你是说，预测基本上是太空竞赛，基本上在太空领域会有更多的竞争，还有更多，为了做一个具体的预测，我会说你会看到，到2021年底，第一次定期安排的游客发射。所以我认为，是的，这听起来很棒。我不知道，我应该先看看他们的时间表。他们可能发布了他们的时间表，所以我可能可以作弊。是的，你看，就像，哦，好吧，那个赌注就那样了。是的，我去年对今年的预测是，嗯，我相信是，我得再确认一下，但我认为那是教育，或者也许那是我们有一个长期和一个短期的赌注。我认为我的长期赌注是
education was going to change where instead of getting scholarship instead of instead of taking out loans you would get sponsored um and so basically the loads basically the loads would become privatized that was the prediction some of that i haven't seen it become regular yet but i've seen people talking a lot about it yeah i think the the inflection point there the tipping point there is is the um they is the government bailout so if the government bails out the student debt well then then all the private investors who would be investing in students will will just punch out because um because the government will just give the we'll just bail out everyone's debt they're not going to be selective or like economic about it um but if they don just bail out everyone's debt. They're not going to be selective or economic about it.
教育将会改变，在那里，与其获得奖学金，与其贷款，你会被赞助。所以基本上，贷款会私有化。这就是预测。其中一些，我还没有看到它变得常规，但我看到人们谈论它很多。是的，我认为那里的拐点，那里的临界点是政府救助。所以如果政府救助学生债务，那么所有会投资学生的私人投资者就会退出，因为政府会直接救助每个人的债务。他们不会有选择性或经济上的考虑。但如果他们不救助每个人的债务，他们就不会有选择性或经济上的考虑。
But if they don't bail out the student debt, then yeah, I think that will accelerate. Cool. Do you remember your question from last year? I was trying to look because I was wondering the same thing and I could not find it. I have no idea what mine was. It was probably wrong or too early
但如果他们不救助学生债务，那么是的，我认为这会加速。酷。你还记得你去年的问题吗？我试着找，因为我也在想同样的事情，但我找不到。我不知道我的是什么。它可能错了，或者太早了。
we'll see we'll see we'll jump into questions so um we could just go straight down the line here um so so senor laser uh on on discord asks uh have we done unit testing in college um i could just say a very quick no. I mean, I wish. It probably would have helped my software development skills accelerate faster. But unit testing was something I learned later. What about you? The same.
我们会看到的，我们会看到的，我们会跳到问题上。所以，我们可以直接按顺序来。所以，Discord上的Senor Laser问，我们在大学里做过单元测试吗？我可以给出一个非常快的“没有”。我的意思是，我希望做过。这可能有助于我的软件开发技能更快地提升。但单元测试是我后来才学到的东西。你呢？一样。
I will say that I think unit testing, to be honest, writing a unit test isn't that... This sounds crazy. The idea of writing a unit test or whatever isn't that big a deal. The biggest thing is getting people to agree to commit to architecting your software in a way that it can be meaningfully unit tested. Yeah, that's a good point. I think that's a topic that might be, for at least the kind of classes and stuff I had in college, I don't think even if someone had tried to make the point, it would have stuck. Yeah, I totally agree. Yeah, now that you mentioned it, I think, you know, I did take a software architecture class in college, and I'm pretty sure they
我会说，我认为单元测试，老实说，写一个单元测试并不是那么……这听起来很疯狂。写单元测试或类似东西的想法并不是什么大不了的事。最重要的是让人们同意致力于以一种可以有意义地进行单元测试的方式来架构你的软件。是的，这是一个很好的观点。我认为这是一个话题，对于至少我在大学里上的那种课程和东西，我不认为即使有人试图提出这个观点，它也会被记住。是的，我完全同意。是的，既然你提到了，我想，你知道，我在大学里确实上过软件架构课，而且我很确定他们
covered this. But as you said, like without any context, without a bigger system, it just sounds, it just doesn't make a lot of sense. It's like, oh, I did this homework assignment. It's like a one file program with two functions. Why would I unit test this, right? And so it only makes sense when you start introducing things like real time clocks and very large, complicated, you know, architectures that then you realize like how important it is and also how hard it is. It is hard.
涵盖了这个。但正如你所说，没有任何背景，没有一个更大的系统，它只是听起来，它只是没有多大意义。就像，哦，我做了这个家庭作业。这就像一个有两个函数的单文件程序。我为什么要对这个进行单元测试，对吧？所以只有当你开始引入像实时时钟和非常大、复杂的架构时，它才有意义，然后你意识到它有多重要，以及它有多难。这确实很难。
And I think as a junior person coming in on a team, sometimes, even if school taught you the importance of it, and kind of how to do it, you wouldn't have the right political capital and angling and experience to understand the right application of it, like the right amount. I'm not a big you know, you don't have infinite money to spend on it. So you should focus your things. Now, if you have infinite money, sure. But, or infinite time, I should say, but time is money. Oh, another topic. For unit testing, I think it's one of those things you need to be very specific in how and what you unit test. If you're not going to be able to do full testing, which most of the time, it's not the right answer to do full testing. And I think that's something that's learned skill over time and specific to an organization and a project, what layer in the stack you are, how you relate
而且我认为作为一个初级人员进入团队，有时，即使学校教了你它的重要性，以及如何做，你也不会有正确的政治资本、角度和经验来理解它的正确应用，比如正确的数量。我不是一个大……你知道，你没有无限的钱花在它上面。所以你应该专注于你的事情。现在，如果你有无限的钱，当然。或者无限的时间，我应该说，但时间就是金钱。哦，另一个话题。对于单元测试，我认为这是你需要非常具体地了解如何以及测试什么的事情之一。如果你不能进行全面测试，这在大多数情况下，不是进行全面测试的正确答案。而且我认为这是随着时间推移学到的技能，并且特定于组织和项目，你在堆栈中的哪一层，你如何关联
to the teams around you, all of that kind of stuff. Yep, totally agree. I second that 100%. All right, I'll ask the next question. So this one's from Canon, and it's, how do you know which path of computer science to go down? Data scientists, computer engineering, yeah, fill in the blank here. So I guess the trend is to answer your own question first. So I ask this one. I'll say that you don't know. I don't think there's a knowing, or at least in my opinion. I think you try to find the one
到你周围的团队，所有这些事情。是的，完全同意。我100%支持这一点。好的，我来问下一个问题。所以这个来自Canon，它是，你怎么知道该走哪条计算机科学路径？数据科学家，计算机工程，是的，在这里填空。所以我猜趋势是先回答你自己的问题。所以我问这个。我会说你不知道。我不认为有什么“知道”，或者至少在我看来。我认为你尝试找到那个
that interests you the most at the time while being open to the idea that you might pick wrong. So some of it is depending on your school schedule availability, how it meshes with classes you're interested in or minors that you need to do. And so I think don't get too hung up on it. As someone who does hiring, I don't care too much, to be honest. And I can't say that's true for everyone. But for me, I kind of don't care. Like, I'm just looking to see if you have a vaguely applicable, if it says electrical engineer, computer science, computer architect, i'm basically treating all those as the same um especially for undergraduate you know first job um kind of hires and so it it matters that you're passionate and that you've got enough exposure to projects to be able to intelligently talk about the uh sort of intricacies of programming and debugging and that kind of thing
在当时最让你感兴趣的，同时对你可能选错的想法保持开放。所以其中一些取决于你的学校时间表可用性，它如何与你感兴趣的课程或你需要做的辅修课程相匹配。所以我认为不要太纠结于它。作为一个招聘人员，老实说，我不太关心。我不能说这对每个人都适用。但对我来说，我有点不关心。就像，我只是在看你是否有模糊适用的，如果它写着电气工程师、计算机科学、计算机架构，我基本上把所有这些都视为一样。特别是对于本科，你知道，第一份工作之类的招聘。所以重要的是你充满热情，并且你有足够的项目接触经验，能够聪明地谈论编程和调试的复杂性等等。
um if you're going to continue, I'll let Jason talk about, you know, past undergraduate, I think it might matter more. But I think early on, I think it matters that you do something that you find really interesting. And it has classes that you think you're going to be passionate and apply yourself to, so that you're going to be involved in the projects and get good grades and that kind of thing. And then I think, after you join, you still, you know, your first job, you still shouldn't settle down, you should try a few different things to see what you really like before settling down on one thing, because that'll also give you breadth
如果你要继续，我会让Jason谈谈，你知道，本科之后，我认为这可能更重要。但我认为早期，我认为重要的是你做一些你觉得真正有趣的事情。并且它有你认为你会充满热情并投入其中的课程，这样你就会参与到项目中并获得好成绩等等。然后我认为，在你加入之后，你仍然，你知道，你的第一份工作，你仍然不应该安定下来，你应该尝试一些不同的事情，看看你真正喜欢什么，然后再决定做一件事，因为那也会给你广度
and confidence and what you chose. So what do you think, Jason? Yeah, that makes a ton of sense. I mean, just some more, like uh some just to riff on that i think um um yeah i remember being in in you know i guess senior year of high school and and really kind of stressing about this choice and there was computer scientists there was computer engineer there was electrical engineer and um and yeah patrick's exactly right. I mean, don't stress too much about this. I think that your career is going to take a really, really long time. And think about all the things that you've learned. Let's say you're a senior in high school.
和信心，你选择了什么。所以你怎么看，Jason？是的，这非常有道理。我的意思是，再多一点，就像，嗯，一些只是为了即兴发挥，我认为，嗯，是的，我记得在，你知道，我想是高中的最后一年，真的有点为这个选择感到压力，有计算机科学家，有计算机工程师，有电气工程师，而且，是的，Patrick说得完全正确。我的意思是，不要为这个感到太大的压力。我认为你的职业生涯会持续很长很长的时间。想想你学到的所有东西。假设你是高中的最后一年。
Think about everything you've learned in those four years. You started with maybe you're in Algebra 1 or something in freshman year or pre-algebra or whatever it is. And then now you've taken, you know, maybe you've taken pre-calc, you know, AP calc. And so you've learned all that stuff in four years. And that's just four years, right? You're probably going to be working for 40 years, right? That's an order of magnitude more. And, and so, you know, I mean, you know, I would look at the courses and just say, okay, which of these sort of curriculum, which is curricula do I prefer? And, and kind of go from there.
想想你在那四年里学到的所有东西。你开始时可能是在大一学代数1或类似的东西，或者预代数，或者其他什么。然后现在你已经修了，你知道，也许你修了预微积分，你知道，AP微积分。所以你在四年里学到了所有这些东西。那只是四年，对吧？你可能会工作40年，对吧？那是一个数量级更多。而且，所以，你知道，我的意思是，你知道，我会看看课程，只是说，好吧，这些课程，哪一个课程我更喜欢？然后，从那里开始。
But yeah, I mean, you know, a good employer will, will, you know, treat a lot of these as, as sort of equivalent. Um, yeah, actually. So you also asked about, yeah, the, once you get to the higher level, then, then you really need to have something, you know, very specific you're passionate about. So, um, so in my case, you know, I really liked, um, um, you know, this idea of like a superhuman, you know, board game player. And so that was something that was, was really appealing to me. And, um, you know, there was chess, right. Where there was deep blue at chess, but the deep blue was sort of a search thing. It didn't really have a good representation of chess. It could just, you know, search really well. Um, you know know and by a good representation
但是是的，我的意思是，你知道，一个好的雇主会，你知道，把很多这些视为，你知道，某种等同的。嗯，是的，实际上。所以你也问过，是的，一旦你到了更高的水平，那么，那么你真的需要有一些，你知道，你非常热衷的特定东西。所以，嗯，在我的情况下，你知道，我真的很喜欢，嗯，嗯，你知道，这个像超人一样的棋盘游戏玩家的想法。所以那是对我非常有吸引力的东西。而且，嗯，你知道，有国际象棋，对吧。有深蓝在国际象棋上，但深蓝是一种搜索的东西。它并没有真正好的国际象棋表示。它只能，你知道，搜索得非常好。嗯，你知道，通过好的表示
i mean something where you can kind of tessellate like you could take one experience and translate it to a slightly different experience right so deep blue didn't really do a whole lot of that and if it did it was it was human beings going in and writing rules um and so that that was just super interesting to me and i was willing to spend a lot of years to try and make progress there um so i think you know it's it's it's kind of difficult to do a something like a phd if you don't have a specific goal um of course you have time to to find that goal but um but ideally you you you know say you do a bachelor's, you do a master's, hopefully by the end of the master's, you have some really interesting question that nobody
我的意思是你可以某种程度上镶嵌的东西，就像你可以采取一种经验并将其转化为稍微不同的经验，对吧？所以深蓝并没有真正做很多那种事情，如果它做了，那是人类进去写规则。所以那对我来说超级有趣，我愿意花很多年去尝试并在那里取得进展。所以我认为，你知道，如果你没有一个特定的目标，做像博士学位这样的事情是有点困难的。当然，你有时间去找到那个目标，但是，但是理想情况下，你，你知道，说你读了学士学位，你读了硕士学位，希望在硕士学位结束时，你有一些真正有趣的问题，没有人
has ever answered before, or that hasn't been, you know, that that has dimensions to it that haven't been explored. You know, we know, there's always been sort of people who get into the PhD program just because they really enjoy school. But then it's very hard to finish without having that kind of specific answer. So that's where I think it can kind of pivot to where you kind of have to have some focus. But yeah, for undergrad and even for master's, yeah, I think looking at the curriculum and don't worry about getting it wrong. You can switch or you could even just finish out the degree and get a job where you're going to be surrounded by people with the other degree and it won't be an issue um okay so so chef asks which programming language should i pick to
以前回答过，或者还没有被，你知道，那有尚未探索的维度。你知道，我们知道，一直都有那种仅仅因为他们真的很喜欢学校而进入博士项目的人。但如果不具备那种具体的答案，就很难完成。所以我认为这可以转向你需要有一些焦点的地方。但是是的，对于本科甚至硕士，是的，我认为看看课程，不要担心选错。你可以转换，或者你甚至可以完成学位并找到一份工作，在那里你会被拥有其他学位的人包围，这不会是一个问题。嗯，好的，所以，所以Chef问我应该选择哪种编程语言来
land a programming job um yeah i mean i'm gonna have a a very specific take on this patrick will probably this is one where we'll probably have a different take um but you know my take on it is is um i think that you know again if you so landing the job is is one thing but then you know you have to work that job right and ideally you have to work that job let's say a minimum of two and a half years so that's what six thousand hours right and it's very hard to do six thousand hours of something that you hate right um so so you really gotta look at what are the kind of things you want to build um and then say okay the people who are building these things what are they using so for example if you wanted to make a video game well like a lot of people are using unity it seems seems like a really powerful engine for that right and so a lot of those people are using c sharp
找到一份编程工作。是的，我的意思是，我会对此有一个非常具体的看法，Patrick可能会，这是我们可能会有不同看法的一个。但是，你知道，我的看法是，嗯，我认为，你知道，再次，如果你，所以找到工作是一回事，但然后，你知道，你必须做那份工作，对吧？而且理想情况下，你必须做那份工作，假设至少两年半，所以那是六千小时，对吧？做六千小时你讨厌的事情是非常困难的，对吧？所以，所以你真的必须看看你想构建什么样的东西。然后说，好吧，那些正在构建这些东西的人，他们在使用什么？例如，如果你想制作一个视频游戏，嗯，就像很多人在使用Unity，看起来是一个非常强大的引擎，对吧？所以很多人在使用C#。
right and so that can kind of help guide your decision but it's coming at it from kind of a different angle what's uh what's your take on that so i guess just to wrap it up i think yeah try to find you know what you want to build and then the language will usually kind of fall out from there that's my take on it i mean i think so i guess uh there's two things there's like uh generally speaking and then like in my current personal experience. So I will say that I guess Jason's saying is kind of true. If you have your eye on a certain kind of job, you might
对，所以这可以在一定程度上指导你的决定，但它是从一个不同的角度来看待问题的。你对此有什么看法？所以我想总结一下，我觉得是的，试着去找到你想构建的东西，然后编程语言通常会随之确定下来，这就是我的看法。我的意思是，我想是的，所以我想有两件事，一个是广义上的，另一个是我目前的个人经验。所以我得说，我想杰森说的是对的。如果你盯着某种特定的工作，你可能
want to tailor your programming language to that kind of job. So if you want to work in machine learning, then, I mean, Jason can probably speak to that, I probably wouldn't recommend learning low level C and C++. Probably not a great fit. If you want to do embedded programming, or even video game programming, for the most part, I would probably not recommend something like Python,
会想要根据那种工作来调整你的编程语言。所以如果你想从事机器学习，那么，我的意思是，杰森可能对此更有发言权，我可能不会推荐学习底层的 C 和 C++。这可能不太合适。如果你想做嵌入式编程，甚至是视频游戏编程，在大多数情况下，我可能不会推荐像 Python 这样的语言，
I'd probably recommend, you know, C++, or even I guess, if you're going to use Unity, you have more flexible, like C sharp or something. It's not that you can't do them in other ones, but it's not about what you can or can't do for a project. It's making yourself have the best chance of getting hired. You may be a really good fit or capable of doing a job and not land that job because either there was somebody else already lined up, the job falls through.
我可能会推荐，你知道，C++，或者我想，如果你要使用 Unity，你有更灵活的选择，比如 C# 之类的。并不是说你不能用其他语言来做，但这与你能做什么或不能做什么项目无关。这是为了让你自己有最大的机会被录用。你可能非常适合或者有能力胜任一份工作，但却没能得到那份工作，因为要么已经有人选了，要么工作机会泡汤了。
I don't really see... H hiring isn't a perfect thing. It doesn't. The perfect people don't get the job every time. Sometimes the interviewer is having a bad day. So what you're trying to do is increase your, you know, sort of chances of getting getting a job. And for that, and like, if you're just saying, look, I want to make sure I get a job, you know, I think there are a few languages you want to choose from, and it varies by field. But if you're going to do web type programming, which isn't Jason and my specialty, then for sure you want to know at least some amount of JavaScript, right? You're going to need to know that.
我真的不觉得……招聘并不是一件完美的事情。它不是。最完美的人并不总是能得到这份工作。有时面试官心情不好。所以你要做的是增加你获得工作的机会。为此，如果你只是说，看，我想确保我能找到一份工作，你知道，我认为有几种语言你可以选择，而且因领域而异。但如果你要从事网页编程，那不是我和杰森的专长，那么你肯定至少需要了解一些 JavaScript，对吧？你需要知道那个。
You're going to know how to build web pages. If you want to do, you know, applications programming on, you know, computers, you're probably going to want to do either like C++, or maybe Java, or maybe something like C sharp, or newer, if you want to do like, you know, Android or iOS programming, something that's more tailored to those. So, you know, something like Swift on iOS, or, you know, I don't even Android, I guess, Kotlin, Kotlin is it I don't know how to say it, but as I was gonna say, which is, you know, kind of related to Java. So I think those are the kind of things but more importantly, you'd want to be building the more specific you are and what job
你需要知道如何构建网页。如果你想做，你知道，计算机上的应用程序编程，你可能想要使用 C++，或者 Java，或者 C#，或者更新的语言，如果你想做 Android 或 iOS 编程，那就选择更适合这些平台的语言。所以，你知道，像 iOS 上的 Swift，或者，你知道，我甚至不知道 Android，我想是 Kotlin，Kotlin 是吗，我不知道怎么读，但正如我刚才要说的，它与 Java 有点关系。所以我认为这些是这类事情，但更重要的是，你想要构建的东西越具体，你想要的工作
you want, you'd want to have projects where you're actually building those things. And those will some to dictate your language. So if you're going to be trying to get a job in Android development, you're going to have one, you're going to want to have built Android apps. And so I think, you know, languages like Python, Java, C++, C sharp, you know, the languages are sort of, you know, JavaScript, most interviewers are going to be able to read those languages. And so you're not going to have a problem, unless you have a very highly specific kind of interview. And, you know, without getting off into it completely, I mean, there's different styles of interviewing that take place at different companies.
你想要什么，你就应该有实际构建这些东西的项目。而这些项目在某种程度上会决定你的语言。所以如果你想在 Android 开发领域找工作，你肯定想要构建过 Android 应用程序。所以我认为，你知道，像 Python、Java、C++、C#，你知道，这些语言，JavaScript，大多数面试官都能读懂这些语言。所以你不会有问题的，除非你参加的是非常特殊的面试。而且，你知道，不完全跑题的话，我的意思是，不同公司有不同的面试风格。
A lot of the tech companies currently do a more data structure algorithm heavy interview. And so as long as if you're programming in a language that the interviewer knows or can read, then you're sort of good to go. And they're looking for more skills. But that's not always true. If you're looking to be productive day one at a smaller shop or a startup or something, then your programming language choice matters to be more closely matched to what that shop does, you know, especially if the shop is doing something different than sort of the beaten path. So if there's some place you really want a job at that does Haskell, you're gonna have to know how to do Haskell. But I would say
目前很多科技公司进行更偏向数据结构和算法的面试。所以只要你使用的编程语言是面试官知道或能读懂的，那么你就没问题。他们寻找的是更多的技能。但这并不总是正确的。如果你想在小型公司或初创公司等地方从第一天起就提高生产力，那么你的编程语言选择就需要与该公司的业务更紧密地匹配，你知道，特别是如果该公司做的事情与常规路径不同的话。所以如果有些地方你真的很想去工作，而他们使用 Haskell，你就必须知道如何使用 Haskell。但我会说
that's not the commonplace. Most of the big tech companies, I'll say, any major language is probably acceptable. And if not, you know, this is hard to say. So if your goal is to just get a job, I guess I would say probably JavaScript, Python, Java, C++. Yeah, I totally agree. If you're wanting to be passionate and build projects and get hired that way, then I would say this question is probably missing the boat there.
那不是普遍情况。大多数大型科技公司，我会说，任何主流语言可能都是可以接受的。如果不是，你知道，这很难说。所以如果你的目标只是找一份工作，我想我会说可能是 JavaScript、Python、Java、C++。是的，我完全同意。如果你想充满热情并构建项目并以此获得录用，那么我会说这个问题可能找错方向了。
It's not about what programming language you learn, but about what you've built. Yeah, totally makes sense. I think, yeah, just bootstrapping off that, if someone interviews you know, interviews for like a machine learning engineer role and they've never coded in Python, that could be kind of a red flag.
重点不在于你学习什么编程语言，而在于你构建了什么。是的，完全有道理。我想，是的，基于这一点，如果有人面试，你知道，面试机器学习工程师的角色，而他们从未用 Python 编写过代码，那可能是一个危险信号。
You know, it's like, it's possible, but it just seems kind of odd, right? So even if, you know, Unity will let you write code in JavaScript or something, knowing sort of the core language that's the most common for whatever kind of field you're wanting to get into is probably important. So maybe the answer is really just to do both, right? I mean, for the type of job you want,
你知道，这就像，这是可能的，但看起来有点奇怪，对吧？所以即使，你知道，Unity 会让你用 JavaScript 或其他语言编写代码，了解你想要进入的任何领域中最常见的核心语言可能很重要。所以也许答案真的只是两者兼顾，对吧？我的意思是，对于你想要的工作类型，
learn the most common language for that job. So if it's web, learn JavaScript, right? But then at the same time, try to also build things. And those things that you want to build might be easier to build in C++. So maybe you have to learn two languages. And that kind of segues nice into our next question from Matt, which is, what is the fastest way to learn a
学习该工作最常用的语言。所以如果是网页，就学习 JavaScript，对吧？但同时，也要尝试构建一些东西。而那些你想构建的东西可能用 C++ 构建更容易。所以也许你必须学习两种语言。这很好地过渡到了马特提出的下一个问题，即学习一门
new programming language? I think of, you know, my view of it is to just find something to build in that language. You know, I think that, so, well, actually, there's sort of a meta question here, which is like, what does it mean to know a language um or you know and and i think the only way you really know if you've learned a language is that you can build something with it um i think there's a lot of um sort of meta you know it's beyond just writing the syntax and all that but there's kind of um different languages have sort of a different let's say like feel to them or like if you're writing you know javascript and this has kind of changed nowadays because there's the weight async pattern in in javascript 6 but um you know traditionally javascript would just have a lot
新编程语言最快的方法是什么？我想，你知道，我的观点是只要找到可以用该语言构建的东西。你知道，我认为，嗯，实际上，这里有一个元问题，那就是，了解一门语言意味着什么，或者你知道，我认为你真正知道自己是否学会了一门语言的唯一方法就是你能用它构建东西。我认为有很多，嗯，某种元知识，你知道，它不仅仅是编写语法等等，而是不同的语言有不同的，比如说，感觉，或者如果你在编写，你知道，JavaScript，而且现在这种情况已经改变了，因为 JavaScript 6 中有 await async 模式，但是，你知道，传统上 JavaScript 会有很多
of callbacks because like every function you would pass in another function maybe even two functions the second one would would fire if if something failed and so you have to structure your code a certain way you know for example that failure callback you might have one failure function globally and you're just passing that to every function you call and and um and so sort of structuring your code in a way to handle like all of those callbacks um you know that goes beyond just being able to have code that compiles right and so you won't know that if you um just learn the language through like a tutorial that teaches you the syntax and so i guess the fastest
回调，因为就像每个函数你都会传入另一个函数，甚至可能是两个函数，第二个函数会在某些事情失败时触发，所以你必须以某种方式构建你的代码，你知道，例如那个失败回调，你可能在全局范围内有一个失败函数，你只是把它传递给你调用的每个函数，而且，所以以某种方式构建你的代码来处理所有这些回调，你知道，这不仅仅是能够编写能编译的代码，对吧？所以如果你只是通过教授语法的教程来学习这门语言，你不会知道这些。所以我猜最快
way to learn the language is that is also the way to know you've learned it which is because you've built things right yeah i i think you have a really good point there i i you always call that i don't language is also the way to know you've learned it, which is to just build things, right? Yeah, I think you have a really good point there. I always call that, I don't know if it's completely correct, writing idiomatic code. So you'll hear it referred to in Python as writing Pythonic code, right? Or maybe that's the one that has the best, or at least the one I know name for it. But you know, as a C++ programmer, I can always tell when someone comes from Java or from C background, and they've learned the syntax, and then they think they know and then it's like, well, what you're writing is technically correct and does work, which is sort of what one of Jason's
学习语言的方法也是知道你已经学会它的方法，那就是因为你构建了东西，对吧？是的，我认为你在这里说得很有道理。我总是称之为，我不知道这是否完全正确，编写地道的代码。所以你会听到在 Python 中被称为编写 Pythonic 代码，对吧？或者也许那是最好的，或者至少是我知道名字的那个。但是你知道，作为一个 C++ 程序员，我总是能看出某人是来自 Java 还是 C 背景，他们学会了语法，然后他们认为他们懂了，然后就像，好吧，你写的东西在技术上是正确的，而且确实有效，这正是杰森的
bars was. But for me, as a person with more years, I would say that, you know, this isn't code that it would have, I would point out various reasons why it's not the way we do it. But to be honest, the same is true for people who study C++ in school, and then they come to the job, for instance, and they use like exceptions, they throw exceptions. And in C++, we have a, you know, variety of lessons learned as to why we've chosen not to throw exceptions normally in our code. And that's something that until we show them, they wouldn't know about those reasons. And maybe they agree or disagree. But all that subtlety, right, is something that I got to ask, what do you do if you don't throw exceptions? So normally, you require functions, well, depends. But either you return some sort of error code, and you have error handling, or you have a kind of separate
标准之一。但对我来说，作为一个更有经验的人，我会说，你知道，这不是我会写的代码，我会指出各种原因说明为什么这不是我们做事的方式。但老实说，对于在学校学习 C++ 然后来到工作岗位的人来说也是如此，例如，他们使用异常，他们抛出异常。而在 C++ 中，我们有，你知道，各种经验教训，说明为什么我们选择不在代码中正常抛出异常。这是在向他们展示之前，他们不会知道这些原因。也许他们同意或不同意。但所有这些微妙之处，对吧，是我必须问的，如果你不抛出异常，你会怎么做？所以通常，你要求函数，嗯，视情况而定。但要么你返回某种错误代码，并且你有错误处理，或者你有一种单独的
separate mechanism for doing it but basically for code that can fail you uh you can have an optional return type you can have a return type that's an error code yeah um it depends on other choices you've made in the system um but yeah so i mean i think part of learning the language as jason said is like and we talk about this and this is true for every language i think we we all ask people who we interview you know hey like how would you rate yourself at c++ programming and they'll say oh you know i'm an eight or nine out of ten and we're just like uh what um and maybe it's more of a c++ joke i guess but c++ has been around for i don't know how many decades now, a lot.
单独的机制来做这件事，但基本上对于可能失败的代码，你可以有一个可选的返回类型，你可以有一个作为错误代码的返回类型，是的，嗯，这取决于你在系统中做出的其他选择，但是是的，所以我的意思是，我认为学习语言的一部分正如杰森所说，就像，我们谈论这个，我认为这对每种语言都是如此，我们都会问我们面试的人，你知道，嘿，你如何评价自己的 C++ 编程水平？他们会说，哦，你知道，我是 10 分里的 8 或 9 分，我们只是觉得，呃，什么，也许这更多是一个 C++ 笑话，我想，但 C++ 已经存在了，我不知道有多少十年了，很久了。
And there's many... Yeah, since the 70s, I think. Yeah, so there's many, many corners to the language. And, you know, we say people who, you know, are writing the standard library and on the panels for the new proposals for next year's thing, those people probably rate themselves as seven or eight in the language. Most of us probably rate ourselves as like four or five. And so it's sort of one of these joking things, but it somewhat holds true, which is the higher you rate yourself, the most likely that you just don't know what you're doing yet. And so most people probably start off rating
而且有很多……是的，我想从 70 年代开始。是的，所以这门语言有很多很多角落。而且，你知道，我们说那些，你知道，正在编写标准库并参与明年提案小组的人，那些人可能给自己打 7 或 8 分。我们大多数人可能给自己打 4 或 5 分。所以这是一种开玩笑的事情，但它在某种程度上是成立的，那就是你给自己打的分越高，你越有可能还不知道自己在做什么。所以大多数人可能一开始给自己打
themselves a one, two, three, four, five, six, seven, eight, two. And so you get somewhere where you start learning that you have more to learn than you thought you did. And you become more self-aware. And so part of learning a language, as Jason points out, is like, look, I can pick almost any language. I won't say any because we've been doing this show a long time. There's a lot of weird languages. But pretty much any language, you can pick up,
1、2、3、4、5、6、7、8、2 分。所以你到了某个阶段，你开始意识到你比你想象的要学的东西更多。你变得更有自我意识。所以学习语言的一部分，正如杰森指出的那样，就像，看，我可以挑选几乎任何语言。我不会说任何语言，因为我们做这个节目很长时间了。有很多奇怪的语言。但几乎任何语言，你都可以拿起，
Google a few things, go on to Stack Overflow and bang out, you know, a simple script or, you know, a hello world example, or even something more complicated. But that's the between that and writing maintainable, you know, 10, 20, 100,000 line projects, right? The gap there is gigantic. And I don't think there's a fast way to get to the writing maintainable. Many people working on a code base code that I don't think there's
谷歌搜索一些东西，去 Stack Overflow，敲出一个，你知道，简单的脚本，或者，你知道，一个 Hello World 示例，甚至更复杂的东西。但那与编写可维护的，你知道，10、20、10 万行项目之间的差距，对吧？那里的差距是巨大的。而且我不认为有什么快速的方法可以达到编写可维护的代码。许多人在代码库上工作，我不认为有什么
a shortcut there. If you're just trying to knock out something for an interview, or for a simple project, or just to get it done, then the fastest way is to be really, really good at one or two languages, so that you know many many concepts in those languages uh and then just figure out why what's the contrast between the language you know and the language you're trying to learn yeah that's it's all really good advice i think um um yeah so so then yeah kind of what you said, if you, if it's going to take a lot of time to learn kind of the right patterns, then yeah, learning a language maybe
捷径。如果你只是想为面试，或者为一个简单的项目，或者只是为了完成它而敲出一些东西，那么最快的方法是精通一两门语言，这样你就知道这些语言中的许多许多概念，然后找出你所知道的语言和你试图学习的语言之间的对比。是的，这真的是很好的建议，我想，嗯，嗯，是的，所以，所以然后，是的，就像你说的，如果你，如果学习正确的模式需要很多时间，那么，是的，学习一门语言也许
isn't like picking a certain language maybe is less important because even if you pick a language for your first job, unless you're going to dedicate a bunch of years to it without working, which would be, which, which probably isn't true't true then then whatever language you pick you you won't have all of that experience anyways so so it's it's maybe more useful to to try and build some cool projects i would also say another way of thinking about is like learning a paradigm and maybe that's too subtle but like if you wanted to learn functional programming right like there's a way to do that in various languages or at least kinds of approaches to a great point right learning how to do scripting right if you really want to learn about banging out
不像选择某种语言那么重要，因为即使你为第一份工作选择了一门语言，除非你打算在不工作的情况下投入几年时间，这可能，这可能不是真的，那么无论你选择什么语言，你都不会拥有所有这些经验，所以，所以尝试构建一些很酷的项目也许更有用。我还会说另一种思考方式是学习一种范式，也许这太微妙了，但如果你想学习函数式编程，对吧，在各种语言中都有方法可以做到这一点，或者至少有某种方法，这是一个很好的观点，对吧，学习如何做脚本，对吧，如果你真的想学习敲出
shell script kind of stuff like c++ is not the right language for that but that's a useful paradigm to know um if you're trying to learn prototyping, GUI, I mean, maybe even paradigm is not the right word. But like learning those kinds of things, there are tools better and worse suited to it. And how close your preferred tool set is, dictates how fast you'll be able to do it. But learning new paradigms, once you learn a paradigm one way, it's often pretty easy to switch between languages within the same kind of thing you're programming yeah another angle on this is you know if you if let's say you set out to learn a language like javascript or c++ or something if you can find a framework and this again assumes that you're you already know kind of you have a project in mind you want to build if you could find a framework that is very opinionated that actually is usually really good um so for example let's say you want
shell 脚本之类的东西，C++ 不是合适的语言，但这是一个有用的范式，如果你试图学习原型设计、GUI，我的意思是，也许范式甚至不是正确的词。但就像学习这类事情一样，有些工具更适合，有些不太适合。你首选的工具集有多接近，决定了你能够多快地完成它。但学习新的范式，一旦你以一种方式学习了一种范式，在同一种编程类型中切换语言通常很容易。是的，关于这个的另一个角度是，你知道，如果你，假设你着手学习像 JavaScript 或 C++ 之类的语言，如果你能找到一个框架，这再次假设你已经知道，你心中有一个项目，你想构建，如果你能找到一个非常有主见的框架，那通常真的很好，嗯，所以例如，假设你想
to learn um let's say you want to learn c++ and you say i'm going to use the google style guide right so the google style guide bans pound defines, right? And so, you know, in the beginning, it might seem kind of frustrating because you might have some idea of a way to use pound defines to like auto generate, you know, 10,000 functions. And then now you can't do that. And so you have to have some way
学习，嗯，假设你想学习 C++，你说我要使用谷歌风格指南，对吧？所以谷歌风格指南禁止 pound defines，对吧？所以，你知道，一开始，这可能看起来有点令人沮丧，因为你可能有一些想法，想用 pound defines 来自动生成，你知道，10,000 个函数。然后现在你不能那样做了。所以你必须有某种方法
to write an abstraction layer so you could get it done in two functions, right? Well, you probably shouldn't have created 10 000 functions right and so and so having that restriction you know the restrictions are trying to restrict you from doing things that that that historically have been bad and so um and so yeah finding sort of these really opinionated frameworks you know you might feel like oh it's kind of restricting me. And every time I try and do something, there's some error or some reason I can't do it. But I think
来编写一个抽象层，这样你就可以用两个函数完成它，对吧？好吧，你可能不应该创建 10,000 个函数，所以，所以有这种限制，你知道，这些限制试图阻止你做那些历史上一直很糟糕的事情，所以，嗯，所以是的，找到这些非常有主见的框架，你知道，你可能会觉得，哦，它在限制我。而且每次我尝试做某事时，总会有一些错误或一些原因我做不到。但我认为
when you're done, and you kind of can do what you want within those restrictions, you're going to find that you're writing kind of more idiomatic code. So the next question comes from gun art is html a programming language no okay next question no um i don't know much about this but yeah go ahead no i mean i i guess it's the hint is in the name it's a markup language um i mean i think you can put stuff in an html file that is programming right you can embed javascript in an html file but i don't don't think HTML, even I won't look, but I'm sure if I look it up, I know CSS is Turing complete. I don't think HTML is, but it might be. But I don't think the normal way people sanely use HTML
当你完成后，并且你可以在这些限制内做你想做的事，你会发现你正在编写更地道的代码。所以下一个问题来自 Gun Art，HTML 是编程语言吗？不，好的，下一个问题。不，嗯，我不太了解这个，但是的，继续。不，我的意思是，我猜提示就在名字里，它是一种标记语言，嗯，我的意思是，我认为你可以在 HTML 文件中放入一些东西，那是编程，对吧？你可以在 HTML 文件中嵌入 JavaScript，但我认为 HTML，即使我不会看，但我肯定如果我查一下，我知道 CSS 是图灵完备的。我不认为 HTML 是，但它可能是。但我认为人们理智地使用 HTML 的正常方式
is more to describe data, right? So this will just make the podcast drag out. But this is a way of modeling data and describing data and annotating data, right? A markup language, you're marking up the data. And then you manipulate it with other tools like, you know, CSS, or which even I won't go there, but or JavaScript or this kind of thing, right? So things like JSON, XML, these are closer in my mind to HTML. And those are all file formats or data descriptors. And they're very, very useful. They're very important tools.
更多是用来描述数据，对吧？所以这只会让播客拖得很长。但这是一种建模数据、描述数据和注释数据的方式，对吧？一种标记语言，你正在标记数据。然后你用其他工具来操作它，比如，你知道，CSS，或者我甚至不会去那里，或者 JavaScript 或这类东西，对吧？所以像 JSON、XML 这样的东西，在我看来更接近 HTML。而这些都是文件格式或数据描述符。它们是非常非常有用的。它们是非常重要的工具。
But I would say those are closer than them to being an actual programming language. Yeah, it totally makes sense. I mean, you know, in absence of JavaScript, I don't think there's any way you can be Turing complete with HTML. So and to Patrick's point, I mean, yeah, looking at it, you know, from a practical perspective, you know, HTML, you know, Markdown, Google Docs, right? I mean, these aren't programming languages. I mean, even if you could show that they're Turing complete, that's not sort of what they're designed for. But I will say that, and maybe I don't know why you're asking this question, or if you're just trying to be funny, or if you're trying to learn something, or trying to understand if it counts to say, you know, HTML, therefore, you know, a programming language or add to your notching up a belt. But I mean, I think understanding good data design and data modeling and data structures is very very important um and so whether or not it's a programming language html is a very important thing um and the paradigm that it represents is also a very important part of uh computer science yeah totally agree totally we actually have a couple of questions that just showed up on the
但我会说那些比它们更接近于真正的编程语言。是的，完全有道理。我的意思是，你知道，在没有 JavaScript 的情况下，我不认为有任何方法可以用 HTML 实现图灵完备。所以，对于帕特里克的观点，我的意思是，是的，从实际角度来看，你知道，HTML，你知道，Markdown，谷歌文档，对吧？我的意思是，这些不是编程语言。我的意思是，即使你能证明它们是图灵完备的，那也不是它们设计的初衷。但我会说，也许我不知道你为什么要问这个问题，或者你只是想搞笑，或者你想学习一些东西，或者想了解它是否算作，你知道，HTML，因此，你知道，编程语言，或者增加你的腰带上的缺口。但我的意思是，我认为理解良好的数据设计、数据建模和数据结构是非常非常重要的，嗯，所以无论它是否是编程语言，HTML 都是一件非常重要的事情，而且它所代表的范式也是计算机科学的一个非常重要的部分。是的，完全同意，完全同意。我们实际上有几个问题刚刚出现在
discord oh um if you're listening live yeah go ahead on the questions channel and throw your question on there and so we'll we'll go through them and then and then we can uh call it a wrap um so so leonhard asks um how relevant is knowledge in a particular business field versus knowledge of the tech stack so so for an example you know how important is it to know uh let's say um web programming versus knowing you know uh next.js or something like that or react or something um yeah it's a good question um i feel like the tech stack is probably less important i mean they're kind of intertwined right because if you've learned a tech stack if you've learned for example next.js then you know something about web programming right um but in other words i wouldn't go out of your way
Discord 上，哦，嗯，如果你在直播收听，是的，请在问题频道继续，把你的问题发上去，然后我们会浏览它们，然后我们就可以结束了，所以，所以 Leonhard 问，嗯，特定业务领域的知识与技术栈知识的相关性如何？所以，举个例子，你知道，了解网页编程与了解，你知道，Next.js 之类的东西，或者 React 之类的东西，有多重要？嗯，是的，这是一个好问题，嗯，我觉得技术栈可能没那么重要，我的意思是，它们有点交织在一起，对吧？因为如果你学习了一个技术栈，如果你学习了，例如 Next.js，那么你就知道一些关于网页编程的东西，对吧？但是换句话说，我不会特意去
to learn you know next.js and uh i think it's called ember.js and angular and react and you know netlify and and all these things um you know i think that that i i would rather people spend their time learning, going into another business field, if that is something they wanted to expand in. Because I feel like once you know one, then you could kind of just contrast and compare to take yourself to the next one. What's your take, Patrick?
学习，你知道，Next.js 和，我想它叫 Ember.js 和 Angular 和 React，你知道，Netlify 和所有这些东西，嗯，你知道，我认为，我宁愿人们花时间学习，进入另一个业务领域，如果那是他们想要扩展的东西。因为我觉得一旦你了解了一个，那么你就可以通过对比和比较来让自己进入下一个。你有什么看法，帕特里克？
This is very, I guess it depends. I mean, a particular business field it depends on the business field i guess right so if if there aren't that many particulars in that business field that make it different than every other one or they're not impactful to the tech stack or the way you build software then i guess it doesn't matter but in some it's probably super relevant. Like if you're going to build safety critical code, right? Like there's a whole,
这非常，我想这取决于情况。我的意思是，特定的业务领域，这取决于业务领域，我想，对吧？所以如果那个业务领域中没有那么多使其不同于其他所有领域的细节，或者它们对技术栈或你构建软件的方式没有影响，那么我想这并不重要，但在某些领域，它可能非常相关。比如如果你要构建安全关键代码，对吧？就像有一个整体，
it influences literally every part of building software. And so it does matter, but it depends. And so I think you got to know, you got to have something in mind before you can get a good answer here. But as a young person or new person, let's say, I would say that it probably doesn't the first thing to worry about. Most places are willing to teach if they're willing to hire an inexperienced person. If you're looking for a more senior experienced role, then it probably matters more.
它实际上影响了构建软件的每一个部分。所以它确实很重要，但这取决于情况。所以我认为你必须知道，你必须在心中有数，才能在这里得到一个好的答案。但作为一个年轻人或新人，比如说，我会说这可能不是第一件要担心的事情。如果他们愿意雇佣一个没有经验的人，大多数地方都愿意教。如果你正在寻找一个更资深、更有经验的角色，那么它可能更重要。
And you sort of need to break into that industry right um but yeah for most people i think there's probably a medium amount of business particulars but that the job is willing to teach them to you yeah that makes sense um so rubik's shoe which is awesome that's a great name it's one of those names that you don't understand it until you phonetically I got it now yes yeah Rubik's shoe asks basically you know should you take a let's say you have a nine-to-five job maybe it's not in computer science, right? Should you take an unpaid internship, you know, in software engineering to try to break into the field? And then sort of the follow-up question is, you know, do you have to sort of quit the day job or could you do both? Why don't you go, Patrick, since I've read two in a row.
而且你需要进入那个行业，对吧，嗯，但是的，对于大多数人来说，我认为可能存在中等数量的业务细节，但工作岗位愿意教给你。是的，这有道理，嗯，所以 Rubik's shoe，这太棒了，这是一个很棒的名字，它是那种你直到发音才明白的名字，我现在明白了，是的，是的，Rubik's shoe 问基本上，你知道，你应该接受一份，比如说，你有一份朝九晚五的工作，也许它不是计算机科学，对吧？你应该接受一份软件工程的无薪实习来尝试进入这个领域吗？然后后续的问题是，你知道，你必须辞掉日常工作吗，还是你可以两者兼顾？为什么你不去，帕特里克，因为我已经连续读了两个了。
This is tough. I mean, this, I think every, it's a, you can hear stories saying either way, you know, you can get whatever confirmation bias you want. So you can find people that say, you gotta, you gotta quit and go all in. And you hear other people say, you gotta never put all your eggs in one basket. And I can probably find you, however many you say is the bar, I can probably find you that many examples of either um and so this is is really hard to know it's it's depending on the market conditions depending
这很难。我的意思是，这，我认为每一个，这是一个，你可以听到各种各样的故事，你知道，你可以得到你想要的任何确认偏见。所以你可以找到那些说，你必须，你必须辞职并全力以赴的人。你也会听到其他人说，你永远不要把所有鸡蛋放在一个篮子里。而且我可能可以为你找到，无论你说多少个是标准，我可能都可以为你找到同样多的例子，无论哪种，嗯，所以这真的很难知道，这取决于市场条件，取决于
on the industry you're trying to go into depending on what your current job is i think this is one of those is very much a case by case i would say there's no one right way to do it um yeah i agree with that i i guess okay one thing i want to add is is just be careful for scams um um you know i think that like uh you know a lot of internships are paid not every internship right um if the internship isn't isn't paid then or if it's let's say significantly less than whatever you're making now, then you have to say, like, what value am I going to really, you know, get out of it, right? So, for example, you know, there might not be, if the internship isn't, let's say, part of some community where, you know, you can get a really good reference and things like that then there might not be that much difference between um an unpaid internship and you just
你试图进入的行业，取决于你目前的工作是什么，我认为这是非常具体情况具体分析的问题，我会说没有一种正确的方法可以做到这一点，嗯，是的，我同意这一点，我，我想，好吧，我想补充的一件事是，小心诈骗，嗯，嗯，你知道，我认为，像，嗯，你知道，很多实习是有薪的，不是每个实习，对吧，嗯，如果实习不是有薪的，或者如果它，比如说，比你现在赚的少得多，那么你必须说，就像，我真的能从中得到什么价值，对吧？所以，例如，你知道，可能没有，如果实习不是，比如说，某个社区的一部分，你知道，你可以得到一个非常好的推荐信之类的地方，那么无薪实习和你只是
spending some time on the side maybe some nights and weekends you know picking up new skills right on the flip side uh there are sort of programs where not only are they unpaid there are programs where you have to pay like these boot camp programs, but there you have to really look at their track record of placing people into jobs, right? And so it might be worth, you know, you actually paying to enroll in something if the, you know, if the expected value of that is high enough, right? And you can look at past graduates and things like that to decide on that. The question of can you do both at the same time?
花一些时间在业余时间，也许是一些晚上和周末，你知道，学习新技能，可能没有太大的区别，对吧？另一方面，嗯，有一些项目，不仅是无薪的，还有一些项目，你必须付费，像这些训练营项目，但你必须真正看看他们将人们安置到工作岗位上的记录，对吧？所以，如果你，你知道，它的预期价值足够高，那么你实际上付费参加某些东西可能是值得的，对吧？你可以看看过去的毕业生之类的事情来决定这一点。关于你是否可以同时做这两件事的问题？
I think the biggest thing is just to be transparent. Now, if you're a nine to five job, like if you're just going to work around that, it probably doesn't matter that much uh but but really with the internship you know you want to be transparent and say look like i have this other job um you know whichever one you're basically joining second you just want to be trans like and this is true in general if ever you're going to join a job but you know keep an existing job you just want to be open about that um and and so whether you should have
我认为最重要的事情就是透明。现在，如果你有一份朝九晚五的工作，就像如果你只是要在那个时间之外工作，那可能没那么重要，嗯，但实际上对于实习，你知道，你想要透明，并说，看，我有这份其他工作，嗯，你知道，无论你基本上是第二个加入哪一个，你只是想要透明，而且这在一般情况下也是如此，如果你要加入一份工作，但你知道，保留一份现有的工作，你只是想要对此保持开放，嗯，而且，所以你是否应该有
two jobs or not uh it really just depends on the circumstances but but the key thing is is just just being open and honest with all the parties involved all right um rubix who also asked about uh music whether they're what we like is there some particular artist is there something we've liked all the way from being a youth to an adult? Uh, something new we've liked. Uh, I'll go first here.
两份工作，这真的取决于具体情况，但关键是，只是对所有相关方保持开放和诚实。好的，嗯，Rubix who 也问了关于音乐的问题，我们喜欢什么，有没有什么特定的艺术家，有没有什么我们从年轻到成年一直喜欢的东西？嗯，我们喜欢的一些新东西。嗯，我先来。
Um, you know, I listened to music fairly often, but I don't feel like I'm a music guy compared to other people. I don't really get that much into bands. I listened to all sorts of things. I mean, when I program,
嗯，你知道，我听音乐相当频繁，但我不觉得我是一个音乐迷，相比其他人。我真的不太喜欢乐队。我听各种各样的东西。我的意思是，当我编程时，
I mostly listened to electronic music of various sorts. Um, and then, but like when I'm driving in the car it's a big mix the other day i was really into like picking bluegrass music i don't know why but i was listening to a lot of like banjos and you know like really really old um stuff i you know i it kind of doesn't matter i'm normally upbeat music person i don't really like sort of like really slow or dark music so that's kind of my only theme but I'm normally upbeat music person. I don't really like sort of like really slow or dark music.
我大多听各种各样的电子音乐。嗯，然后，但是就像我在车里开车时，这是一个大杂烩，前几天我真的很喜欢听蓝草音乐，我不知道为什么，但我听了很多班卓琴，你知道，就像非常非常古老的东西，我，你知道，我，它有点无关紧要，我通常是一个乐观的音乐人，我真的不太喜欢那种非常缓慢或黑暗的音乐，所以这就是我唯一的主题，但我通常是一个乐观的音乐人。我真的不太喜欢那种非常缓慢或黑暗的音乐。
So that's kind of my only theme, but no, there's not been one artist I've listened to, you know, for sort of years and years. And, you know, I would, you know, pay lots of money to go to their concert. That's just not my relationship to music. Yeah. My answer is similar. I would say that I'm, I'm, it sounds like I'm a lot more into music. I mean, I do like, I go to a bunch of concerts. Um, there, there's some bands I really enjoy, but it's, it's nothing specific either. Um, um,
所以这就是我唯一的主题，但没有，没有一个艺术家是我听了，你知道，好多年好多年了。而且，你知道，我会，你知道，花很多钱去听他们的演唱会。那不是我和音乐的关系。是的。我的回答也类似。我会说，我，我，听起来我更喜欢音乐。我的意思是，我确实喜欢，我去了很多演唱会。嗯，有一些乐队我真的很喜欢，但它，它也没有什么特别的。嗯，嗯，
I, I generally don't listen to music when I'm coding or working, but, um, uh, but I do listen to a bunch of music in the car and, or I'll have music playing, you know, like, uh, when we're just hanging out with the kids and things like that. Um, it's all over the place i mean everything from you know country to heavy metal to i don't know rap r&b everything in between and uh i generally you know i like i like same thing as patrick said you know music that are music that is uh more high tempo um you know that's sort of like high energy and get people kind of excited um you know i like music that's some of it is just because it's funny the lyrics are funny like uh um you know like um what is the the people who do the i'm on a boat lonely island or like you know these these sort
我，我通常在编码或工作时不听音乐，但是，嗯，嗯，但我确实在车里听了很多音乐，或者我会播放音乐，你知道，就像，嗯，当我们和孩子们在一起玩之类的时候。嗯，它到处都是，我的意思是，从你知道乡村音乐到重金属到我不知道说唱 R&B，介于两者之间的一切，而且，嗯，我通常，你知道，我喜欢，我喜欢和帕特里克说的一样，你知道，音乐是，音乐是，嗯，节奏更快的，你知道，那是那种高能量的，让人们有点兴奋的，嗯，你知道，我喜欢音乐，其中一些只是因为很有趣，歌词很有趣，比如，嗯，你知道，比如，嗯，什么，那些做 I'm on a boat 的人，Lonely Island，或者像，你知道，这些，这些，
of like goof goofy bands like tom mcdonald uh you, these, these sort of, uh, Adam, Adam Sandler back in the day. So, so yeah, it's kind of a mix of, you know, comedy routines that are musical. Um, and then pretty much every genre across the board. Um, and, but yeah, when I'm working at, I generally don't like to listen to, I generally don't listen to music unless it's it's um a noisy place and i have headphones on um pyro asks if uh we could do a virtual meetup i think that's a decent idea we might try to to see that i think it's gonna be busy for the next few weeks for us but uh um yeah i think virtual meetup might be uh that seems to be very 2020 so it'll probably first half of 2021 be the same kind of thing so um i don't have anything specific planned out but that's that's not a bad idea yeah i mean you know our
这些，嗯，傻傻的乐队，像 Tom McDonald，你，这些，这些，嗯，Adam，Adam Sandler 在过去的日子里。所以，所以是的，这有点像，你知道，是音乐性的喜剧表演。嗯，然后几乎涵盖了所有流派。嗯，但是是的，当我工作时，我通常不喜欢听，我通常不听音乐，除非它是，嗯，一个嘈杂的地方，我戴着耳机，嗯，Pyro 问是否，嗯，我们可以做一个虚拟聚会，我认为这是一个不错的主意，我们可能会尝试看看，我认为接下来的几周对我们来说会很忙，但，嗯，嗯，是的，我认为虚拟聚会可能是，嗯，那看起来非常 2020 年，所以它可能在 2021 年上半年也是同样的事情，所以，嗯，我没有计划任何具体的事情，但那不是一个坏主意。是的，我的意思是，你知道，我们的
christmas episodes are kind of that already uh we just kind of opened the floor um you're here we're here yeah i mean you know i wonder you know and even for the christmas for the holiday episode i was wondering like um you know is there a way to sort of, you know, I know it's zoom people have done like breakout sessions and basically get everyone talking to each other and maybe what we'll do actually, I don't know if this is going to end terribly or not, but we could just open the whole, the whole room up at the end after we're done recording and just let everyone talk to each other and i can spend a little bit of time here uh i'll mute myself and we'll basically invert it we'll mute ourselves and we'll let
圣诞节剧集已经是那样了，我们只是打开了话筒，你在那里，我们在这里，是的，我的意思是，你知道，我想知道，你知道，即使是圣诞节，为了节日剧集，我还在想，嗯，你知道，有没有一种方法可以，你知道，我知道它是 Zoom，人们已经做了像分组讨论会，基本上让每个人互相交谈，也许我们实际上会做的是，我不知道这会不会以糟糕的方式结束，但我们可以在录制结束后打开整个房间，让每个人互相交谈，我可以花一点时间在这里，嗯，我会静音我自己，我们会基本上把它倒过来，我们会静音我们自己，我们会让
everyone in the room get a chance to talk to each other and then i could just kind of leave it running and so we have to post a phone call it's happening it's happening now it's happening yes shake your hands we got two more questions. So next to last question is, have you ever considered doing a startup versus working at a company? I'll answer first again, because I'm selfish. You know, considering doing a startup.
房间里的每个人都有机会互相交谈，然后我可以把它开着，所以我们必须发布一个电话，它正在发生，它正在发生，是的，握握手，我们还有两个问题。所以倒数第二个问题是，你有没有考虑过做初创公司而不是在公司工作？我再次先回答，因为我很自私。你知道，考虑做初创公司。
Yeah, I considered it. I never seriously pursued it myself. Honestly, this gets into a very lengthy discussion, which you probably should have at some time. But I mean, I'm probably very biased. I think again, to my earlier answer, there's a lot of confirmation bias you can find here. I think there's a lot of startups I would probably never join. And then there's some startups I think are legitimately doing good work or even doing one myself. And it's something every I would say probably almost
是的，我考虑过。我从来没有认真地追求过它。老实说，这涉及到非常冗长的讨论，你可能应该在某个时候进行。但我的意思是，我可能非常偏颇。我认为再次回到我之前的回答，你可以找到很多确认偏见。我认为有很多初创公司我可能永远不会加入。然后有一些初创公司我认为确实在做好的工作，甚至我自己也在做。这是每个人，我会说可能几乎
everyone in the tech field considers at some time unless they're currently in a startup. How about you, Jason? Yeah, you someone explained this explained this to me so yeah i'm going to have a similar slant on this as patrick and so take us both with a grain of salt neither of us have ever worked at a startup but um someone explained it to me in a way which i really appreciated um they said that a startup is really good for um people who have like far exceeded their resume so so you know because if you go to a big company they're going to have you know a million you know automated or you know semi you know like like mechanical procedures to to screen people out. And so, um, and so, you know, if you, if you have a ton of talent, um, but you haven't built that resume yet, um, then a startup is a really good option,
科技领域的每个人都在某个时候考虑过，除非他们目前在初创公司。你呢，杰森？是的，你有人向我解释过这个，向我解释过这个，所以是的，我将在这个问题上有与帕特里克相似的倾向，所以我们俩的话都只听一半，我们俩都没有在初创公司工作过，但是，嗯，有人以我非常欣赏的方式向我解释了它，他们说初创公司对于，嗯，那些简历已经远远超出他们能力的人来说真的很好，所以，所以你知道，因为如果你去一家大公司，他们会有，你知道，一百万，你知道，自动化的，或者，你知道，半，你知道，像机械程序来筛选人。所以，嗯，所以，你知道，如果你，如果你有大量的才能，嗯，但你还没有建立那个简历，嗯，那么初创公司是一个非常好的选择，
right? Because, because a startup, you know, they're, they'll typically be a real person on the other end of that form that you submit your resume to. And so I think that's a place where it can be really beneficial. In my case, you know, I was fortunate in that, you know, the area of research that I wanted to do, you know, there were companies that were looking for exactly that area. And so, you know, definitely when I graduated, my resume was probably better than my skills. My C++ skills were not that great, But I put myself as a 9 out of 10 on C++ and I was probably like a 0.5 out of 10. Red flag. decision simple. Of course, anytime you make a decision simple, you're going to expose a whole bunch of corner cases, right? Like, there's always, you know, at one point, all of these
对吧？因为，因为初创公司，你知道，他们，他们通常会在你提交简历的表格的另一端有一个真实的人。所以我认为这是一个非常有益的地方。在我的情况下，你知道，我很幸运，你知道，我想做的研究领域，你知道，有公司正在寻找那个确切的领域。所以，你知道，当我毕业时，我的简历可能比我的技能要好。我的 C++ 技能不是那么好，但我把自己在 C++ 上评为 10 分里的 9 分，而我可能只有 10 分里的 0.5 分。危险信号。决定很简单。当然，任何时候你让决定变得简单，你都会暴露出一大堆极端情况，对吧？就像，总是有，你知道，在某一点上，所有这些
big companies were startups. And if you had joined any of them, you would have been extremely lucky. So take everything with a grain of salt there. But I think that was a very simple way to sort of break it down that I thought made a lot of sense to me um oh the question was have we thought of starting uh uh or or there's sort of a corollary have we ever thought of of starting a startup or like starting a company and um boss asked that question what's that your boss was asking because they wanted to know your boss is trying to figure out if you're starting i'm just kidding oh yeah this person's my boss and yeah i got this email saying hr wants to talk to me right now um no i mean i think it would be interesting um you know there's sort of this
大公司曾经也是初创公司。如果你加入了其中任何一家，那你真是极其幸运。所以对这些话要有所保留。但我认为这是一种非常简单的拆解方式，我觉得对我来说很有道理。哦，问题是我们有没有想过创办一家初创公司，或者说有没有想过创业。老板问了这个问题，那是你老板问的吗？因为他们想知道你老板是不是在试探你是否要创业。我开玩笑的。哦，是的，这个人是我的老板，我确实收到了这封邮件说人力资源部现在想和我谈谈。不，我的意思是，我觉得这会很有趣，你知道，这有点像
meta question of like um specialization versus getting really specific um you know i think that if you work at a startup you're going going, or sorry, specialization versus generalization. And so if you work at a startup, you're going to be doing a bunch of things. You're going to be buying machines probably for the, for the people on the team, or at least someone's going to be doing that. Um, you're going to be hiring people. You're going to be, there's a whole laundry list of things. You're going to be finding out how to pay the Amazon bill, right? The AWS bill. Um, um and and so these are things that a giant company you know it's it's completely the opposite like you you're really focused on a few things and so that's that's really the i think um sort of the the you kind of have to have the
关于专业化与泛化之间的一个元问题。如果你在初创公司工作，抱歉，是专业化与泛化。如果你在初创公司工作，你得做很多事情。你可能得为团队成员购买设备，或者至少有人得做这件事。你需要招聘人员。还有一大堆琐事。你得弄清楚怎么支付亚马逊的账单，也就是AWS账单。这些事情在大型公司里完全相反，你真的只需要专注于几件事。所以这就是我认为你必须先有
answer to that question before you could answer the startup question and then the final question comes from dan what are the plans for the show in 2021? And that's a great segue. And I'll pivot it into asking you, Jason, what are the plans for the show in 2021? And just in general, what are you thinking about 2021? Yeah, so we've already started this, you know, I think we're going to the show is going to become sort of a bit more professional um i think that you know we we switched to a new um um you know recording kind of like uh studio software um i think we'll probably move the podcast on to you know um one of these podcast platforms instead of what we have now. And basically, a lot of the infrastructure that we've set up for the podcast,
在回答初创公司的问题之前，先回答这个问题。最后一个问题来自Dan：2021年节目有什么计划？这是一个很好的过渡。我把它转给你，Jason，2021年节目有什么计划？总的来说，你对2021年有什么想法？是的，我们已经开始了，我认为节目会变得更专业一些。我们换了一个新的录音室软件，我想我们可能会把播客迁移到某个播客平台上，而不是现在这样。基本上，我们为播客建立的很多基础设施，
we set up like a decade ago or something. And so we had an issue a few months back that really kind of made me realize that we need to spend a little bit of time to modernize. And so I'm going to go through and bit of time to modernize and so um you know i'm going to go through and kind of kind of do a lot of that um you know beyond the tech stuff a couple of things i'd like us to do is is to get back to doing um you know our regular show we've had some like unbelievable interview opportunities like peter voss we have some people we've we've already
还是十年前左右建立的。几个月前我们出了个问题，让我意识到我们需要花点时间进行现代化升级。所以我打算花点时间进行现代化改造。除了技术方面，我还想做几件事，比如回归我们的常规节目。我们有一些令人难以置信的采访机会，比如Peter Voss，我们已经有一些人
interviewed that we're going to show everyone next month. And so the interview opportunities have been just amazing. I mean, I actually the other day was searching for application performance management for something I was trying to do at work. And I came across Matt, Matt Watson, who he interviewed. I came across a blog post from him and I wasn't even looking for him specifically. And I wasn't doing the personalized search either. So, I mean, this was just a general search. So, you know, we've had such amazing opportunities, but because of that, we haven't done the regular show in a while. And I am starting to miss that a bit. So, you know, I don't know if we're going to increase the cadence or if we're going to just have to tell some interviewers, you know, we have to push the schedule out. But that is something that, you know, I'd like to see us do. And I guess the last thing is I just want to be a post anything on Twitter other than the show episodes.
采访过了，下个月会展示给大家。采访机会真是太棒了。其实前几天我在工作中搜索应用性能管理时，偶然发现了Matt Watson，就是我们采访过的那位。我看到了他的一篇博客文章，我甚至不是专门在找他，也没有进行个性化搜索。所以，这只是一个常规搜索。我们有这么好的机会，但正因如此，我们有一段时间没做常规节目了。我开始有点怀念了。我不知道我们是否会增加频率，或者是否不得不告诉一些受访者我们需要推迟时间表。但这是我希望我们能做到的。最后一点是，我不想在Twitter上发布除节目剧集以外的任何内容。
But one thing I posted yesterday was a shout out to Vercel and just some of the amazing software they've built. And, you know, I think I'm going to try and do more of that. You know, we have the RSS feed. We have the Patreon feed. And so if people just want to know when a new episode is out, there's plenty of podcast apps will do that. You know, so so I think I could be a little bit more vocal on on the Twitter feed and just kind of tell people, you know, here's some really cool things to check out. Yeah, I guess you kind of covered stuff for the podcast. I mean, in my personal personal life, I mean, I think try to stay safe and healthy for 2021, you know, continue more of the same.
但我昨天发布的一件事是向Vercel致敬，感谢他们构建了一些出色的软件。我想我会尝试多做这类事情。我们有RSS订阅源，有Patreon订阅源。如果人们只是想知道新剧集何时发布，有很多播客应用可以做到。所以我认为我可以在Twitter上更活跃一些，告诉大家这里有一些很酷的东西值得一看。是的，我想你已经涵盖了播客的事情。在我的个人生活中，我想在2021年努力保持安全和健康，继续保持现状。
I think personally, I've been moving more into management and lots of programming. So that's been something that's taught me a lot that it wasn't able to rely on, you know, just my previous work as much because being a technical engineering manager, I guess, everybody has different names for it, you know, is, I always knew what I wanted my managers to do. And now I'm on the other side and trying to be what the engineers, you know, need is something that's a learning opportunity for me. And so I'll probably have a lot more opinions about that kind of stuff in the future. And as I do a little bit less programming, a lot more opinions about that kind of stuff in the future. And as I do a little bit less programming, a little more people work, but it's something that that's been a fun adventure so far. Yeah, I guess for me personally next year.
我个人觉得我正在更多地转向管理，而不是大量的编程。这教会了我很多，因为我不能再像以前那样仅仅依赖我的工作了。作为一名技术工程经理，每个人对这个职位的称呼不同，我一直知道我希望我的经理做什么。现在我站在了另一边，试图成为工程师们所需要的人，这对我是个学习机会。所以我将来可能会对这类事情有更多的看法。随着我编程减少，做更多的人员管理工作，这是一个有趣的冒险。是的，对我个人来说，明年。
Yeah, similar to what Patrick said, you know, I also need to get back on the exercise bandwagon. You know, I think that when I was going into the office, I had a pretty good routine. I'm sure this, you know, a lot of people, maybe the majority of people in the country have sort of the same situation that we do where, yeah, I just haven't really, I don't even know if the gyms are open in my state or anything. So I have to figure a lot of that out on the exercise side. But so yeah, I think 2021 will really be just, I think, finding the new normal, like getting back into routines that we had, you know, before the pandemic. I think that's going to be a big part
是的，和Patrick说的一样，我也需要重新开始锻炼了。我想当我还在去办公室的时候，我有很好的作息。我相信很多人，也许是全国大多数人，都和我们处于同样的情况，我甚至不知道我所在的州健身房是否开放。所以我必须在锻炼方面弄清楚很多事情。所以，我认为2021年将是寻找新常态的一年，就像回到疫情前我们拥有的作息一样。我认为这将是重要的一部分
of it. And it's not going to be the way it was, right? I'm probably going to be remote for the whole year. So, um, um, but, you know, within, you know, even within those changes and you're getting back some of those healthy routines. Um, I think also, you know, on the personal side is, uh, I think I want to try and find something to new to build. You know, I think the eternal terminal was, is, is, you know, awesome. Um, you know, I still use it a lot, and there's still some things I want to build there. But Eternal Terminal was something I built over the holiday break. And so as we come to this next holiday break, I'm trying to think,
而且不会和以前一样了，对吧？我可能全年都要远程办公。但是，即使在这些变化中，也要找回一些健康的作息。我认为在个人方面，我想尝试构建一些新的东西。我认为Eternal Terminal非常棒，我仍然经常使用它，还有一些我想在上面构建的功能。但Eternal Terminal是我在假期期间构建的。所以随着下一个假期的到来，我在想，
what is the next kind of cool thing that I can build that can really help out developers and stuff like that? So yeah, I I think, uh, I think that's, that's it for me. So, um, I just wanted to give a big shout out to, um, everyone out there, you know, our patrons who supported us. Oh, actually, um, um, yeah, we have to, to, uh, um, yeah, we have to, to, uh, definitely acknowledge all the patrons and everyone who, who, you know, has, has, has given us so much support over the year. I think that, um, you know, it's been, it's been amazing watching, you know, the, the
下一个我可以构建的酷东西是什么，能真正帮助到开发者之类的？所以，我想这就是我的想法。我只想向所有支持我们的赞助人表示感谢。哦，其实，我们必须肯定要感谢所有的赞助人，以及所有在这一年里给予我们如此多支持的人。我认为，看着
podcast just continue to grow. And, uh, you know, I think that want to thank all the interviewers who who you know have have really provided such amazing content and commentary in so many different areas and thank everyone who everyone out there who's listening you know people who listen live people who subscribe to the podcast especially people who you know give us give us feedback you know write us in tell us new languages you want to see, tell us people we should interviews. A lot of the interviews came from someone out there emailing us and saying,
播客持续增长真是太棒了。我想感谢所有提供如此精彩内容和评论的受访者，感谢所有收听节目的听众，包括直播听众、订阅播客的人，特别是那些给我们反馈、写信告诉我们想听的新语言、建议我们采访对象的人。很多采访都是来自听众发邮件告诉我们，
Hey, you should talk to this person. So thank you for doing that. And yeah, overall, everyone have a safe, happy holidays. holidays music by eric barn dollar programming throwdown is distributed under a creative commons attribution share alike 2.0 license you You're free to share, copy, distribute, transmit the work, to remix, adapt the work, but you must provide attribution to Patrick and I and sharealike in kind. There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
嘿，你应该和这个人谈谈。所以谢谢你们这样做。总的来说，祝大家节日快乐，平安健康。节目音乐由Eric Barn Dollar提供。Programming Throwdown在知识共享署名-相同方式共享2.0许可下发布。你可以自由分享、复制、分发、传播作品，进行重混或改编，但必须注明Patrick和我，并以相同方式共享。本集暂无评论。点击转录中的任何句子即可发表评论。